das motto teil von berlin was bedeutet
das für den rennsport auf unseren
straßen das nämlich jetzt in einem ganz
neuen zdf ratgeber mit martin klempnow
city ist ob die behörden wollte herzlich
willkommen zum thema biber rasen in den
letzten 20 jahren ist die
durchschnittliche ps zahl bei deutschen
pkw von 95 auf 150 ps gestiegen seien
oder nicht
die renten in deutschland sind immer
noch optimal
65 prozent der autobahn sind tempolimit
frei sah ich wie for speed angesagt und
es ist gesund erst 190 km h ist der
durch gefahr wirklich empfehlen mit 120
gut ein drittel weniger verkehrstote
ja aber dafür ist die überlebenden
schmieden bauzeit langweilig zum glück
für deutschland immer noch von
autoherstellern regiert deswegen fahren
wir auch im gegensatz zu anderen ländern
ja auch du sau wenig für bußgelder hier
zum beispiel handy an der rübe beim
autofahren 60 euro war füße von
schnäppchen aber nur für handy ipad
kopie ist noch arbeitet sogar noch viele
politiker klar sehen diese illegalen
autorennen probleme sind fordere ich
auch schon seit jahren in deutschen
großstädten ausgangssperre für fußgänger
24 stunden kavlak problem gelöst so das
war's auch schon wieder
lassen sie sich nicht immer von einem
verkehrsteilnehmer provozieren das
klingt mal gar nicht
die all den rennen oder
[Musik]
[Applaus]